most of the time when you hear people
talk about big data
they're talking about it within the
commercial setting about how businesses
can use big data in advertising or
marketing strategies
but one really important place that big
data is also used is for consumers
what's funny about this is that while
the data is there and the algorithms are
there
any incredibly sophisticated processing
is there it's nearly invisible
the results are so clean they give you
just a little piece of information but
exactly what you need
what i want to do is show you some
common applications of big data for
consumers that you may be using already
without being aware of the
sophistication of the big data analysis
that's going into it
the first one is if you have an apple
iphone or ipad
is what siri can do for instance aside
from saying what's the weather like
and siri actually knows what it is you
mean and where you are
and what time you're talking about it
can do things like look for restaurants
of a particular kind of food and see if
they have reservations available
it can do an enormous amount of things
that requires the recommendation of
other people
awareness of your locations awareness of
the changes over time of what is most
preferable for people
the next one you might be familiar with
recommendation engines
this is an idea of software that is able
to make a specific suggestion to you
here's a spotify account and spotify
knows what you listen to when you're on
spotify
and what you listen to all the way
through what you add to your playlist
what you skip through and it's able to
make specific suggestions to help you
find new artists that you wouldn't
otherwise know about
similarly amazon.com makes
recommendations for books
for instance here's a book principles of
big data by jules berman
and if you scroll down you'll see that
they have a list of other books that are
recommended
this is generated by amazon's
recommendation engine
and you see several other books on big
data and in fact
it's a great list it's the same general
principle here
a lot of people use netflix to get
movies
netflix makes specific suggestions for
other movies you might like
what's interesting is that a few years
ago they had a major contest called the
netflix prize where they wanted to see
if anybody could improve the accuracy of
their predictions
meaning would you actually like this if
they could improve those predictions by
10 percent
it was a million dollar prize and it was
incredibly sophisticated analysis that
went into this
but the end result again is a very
simple thing you get recommended a
handful of movies
and usually you pick one and you like it
so for consumers
big data plays an enormous role in
providing valuable services
but again with the irony that it
operates invisibly by taking a huge
amount of information from several
different sources and distilling it into
just two or three things that give you
what you need
we saw that big data can provide
important conveniences and functionality
for consumers
but for the business world big data is
revolutionizing the way people do
commerce
we will look at a few particular places
where big data has proven to be
particularly useful
or unusual and interesting the first
thing we're going to do is look at the
place where most people have encountered
big data in commerce
and that's in the results for google ed
searches
you search for something on google or
any other search engine you type in your
term
you're going to get the results that you
want but you're also going to get ads
you see here for instance on the top
when you're searching for big data
there are three ads on the top and there
is a series of ads down the right side
those ads are not placed at random
they're placed there because they are
based first on the thing that you're
currently searching for
but also based on what google knows
about you
you can see in the top right that
someone has logged into his account
so google is drawing on all of the
things that he has searched for
and the other information it has about
him to try to place ads that it thinks
he would be most likely to respond to
that's something it gets by having a
very large amount of data available
to tailor things to be most applicable
to the consumer
another interesting place is what's
called predictive marketing
this is when big data is used to help
decide who the audience would be for
something before they actually get there
this is trying to predict for example
major life events
like for instance graduating or getting
married or getting a new job
or having a child or any number of
events that are often associated with a
whole series of commercial transactions
to do this these companies can look at
consumer behavior
they can look at how often you log on to
their website
they can look at what credit cards you
use they can look at how often you look
at particular items before moving on to
something else
they can look at whether you've applied
for an account at their organization
they can make a huge amount of
information that they already have
available to them
similarly they can use demographic
information
this can include things like your age
your marital status
the number of children you have your
home address how far you live from their
store
your estimated salary if you've moved
recently what credit cards you have
what websites you visit all of this
information is potentially available in
one form
or another to the company that's trying
to make these predictions
similarly they can rely on additional
purchase data
it's possible for the company to get
information about your ethnicity
your job history your magazine
subscriptions whether you've declared
bankruptcy or been divorced
whether you've attended college the kind
of things you talk about online
and so on there's an enormous amount of
information here that again
is potentially available using this kind
of information
it is possible for a company to predict
that you're about to buy a new house
and that when you buy a new house you
make an enormous number of purchases
and so they can link into you before you
start making the commitments to those
another place we want to talk about big
data is trying to predict trends
one of the really fascinating places for
this is in fashion
the company edit has actually received
awards for their use of big data in
predicting fashion trends
so they can actually tell retailers what
the most popular colors and styles and
brands are going to be
when they're going to be popular and
they can help them price them
obviously this kind of information is
enormously important to the companies
that are going to be selling these
products
and edit is able to do this through
their reliance on big data
finally one of the interesting use of
big data in commerce is for fraud
detection
it turns out that fraud is an enormous
industry that online retailers lose
about 3.5 billion dollars each year to
online fraud and insurance fraud
not counting health insurance is
estimated to be more than 40 billion
dollars per year
so fraud is a big issue it turns out
that there's a number of things that
companies can do to lessen the
prevalence of fraud
especially through online transactions
they can look at the point of sale
that specifically means how are you
making the purchase
are you online and what website are you
using
they can use geolocation where are you
physically located
in the world they can look at the ip
address
what computer are you using to access
the website
they can look at the log in time are you
somehow making a purchase at 4am
when you've never before done anything
after 11 pm
interestingly they can also look at
things like biometrics
for instance the way that people move
their mouse or the time they take
between
pressing keys on the computer are
distinctive measurements of people
a lot of this was made possible because
of the particular details and the
patterns that they have in their
extraordinarily large data set
let them recognize these anomalies as
potential fraud
we have looked at the role that big data
can play in individual people's lives as
well as in businesses
we also want to look very quickly at how
big data has been revolutionizing
aspects of scholarship and research
there are a few interesting examples of
where big data has influenced
scientific progress the first one we
want to look at is google flu trends
where they were able to find that search
patterns for flu related words were
actually able to identify
outbreaks of the flu in the united
states much faster than the research
that the center for disease control
could do
similarly a more recent project found
that wikipedia searches could identify
them with even greater accuracy
psychological research has also been
influenced through big data
in 2013 a paper published about
personalities in the united states was
able to identify clusters of
personalities
in regions where we have the midwestern
friendly and conventional region
the western relaxed and creative region
and a northeastern and somewhat southern
temperamental
and uninhibited region this is not based
on simply how do you feel about the
places
but this is published in a journal from
the american psychological association
a very high quality psychological
research
similarly another group of researchers
created an application on facebook that
used a scientifically valid measure of
personality
they collected data from several hundred
thousand respondents
and by combining those with the patterns
of likes that each of those people had
on facebook
to give a surprisingly accurate
evaluation of what your personality
would be
finally the google books project for the
last few years
google has been scanning books that were
published over the last few hundred
years
they currently have over 30 million
books that they have scanned
they make them digitally accessible and
that allows people in digital humanities
to look at the changes in word usage
over time
there's some interesting things for
instance we have the last 208 years of
the prevalence of the word math
arithmetic and algebra
the term arithmetic shows a strong spike
in the 20s and 30s
but it decreases over time whereas the
word math has increased over the last
fifty to sixty years
with a peak right around year two
thousand
these are just some possible examples of
what can be done
but the idea here is that big data with
both the volume of information that's
available
the variety of information that's able
to be combined and with the velocity
especially with things like the flu
trends where things are changing
constantly
all of these are able to make good use
of big data for scientific research and
advancement
it's an exciting time to see what's
happening and to see what will happen in
the near future